y'a pas de sou pénalisation mais il ya
plutôt une sur pénalisation des
agresseurs des forces de l'ordre et
depuis un certain temps et que d'un
autre côté
effectivement les risques pris par les
forces de l'ordre
son passé à peu près de 22% dans la
période des années 70 à 6 % dans la
période 2015-2020 donc de quoi on parle
sinon que bon on sent bien qu'il ya un
effet de dramatisation de nous vivons
dans une société qui serait ou la
violence serait désinhibé où tout le
monde serait agressé bon voilà on
reconnaît là quand même un bon vieux
thème mais moi ce qui me frappe c'est
quand même c'est ces deux choses c'est
que d'un côté
d'une certaine manière ce débat on est
un peu l'indicateur on est en train de
ramener la police via son syndicat
majoritaire
et qui est quand même voilà bien situer
politiquement on en reparlera peut-être
sur le dos de la justice pour expliquer
comment la justice doit procéder c'est
pas du tout un débat sur la police qu'on
a actuellement c'est un débat sur
comment doit fonctionner la justice bon
pour qu'elles soient plus sévères alors
que encore une fois les elle est déjà
bon donc c'est ça qui est inquiétant
c'est là c'est la façon dont il ya le
principe de séparation des pouvoirs est
remis en cause bon et que tout ça se
passe encore une fois sous avec le
soutien notamment du ministre de
l'intérieur bon et en même temps le
soutien d'une partie de la classe
politique mais d'un autre côté ce qui
est frappant c'est que en mettant le
projecteur sur une justice qui sait ce
qui serait décidément en dessous tout
bon d'un autre côté on voit s'accumuler
les dénis c'est à dire que dénis des
violences policières
est ce qu'on parle des éborgné des mains
arrachées des blessés graves à la tête
des morts pendant la période des gilets
jaunes
[Musique]